hey guys now this is going to be a very
interesting
topic how to increase sperm count
naturally now scientists say that in the
last few years the sperm count
in men decreased a lot
and it's getting worse new studies from
the asrm
also shows that american and european
men's sperm count
and sperm motility that is the swimming
ability of sperm cells
have declined in the past decade so
what causes low sperm count and how can
you
increase it well that's what we're going
to talk about in this video
let's get to it
i have a dream
[Music]
just very quick if it's the first time
that you're here on my channel welcome
to diy model lifestyle i'm daniel and
here i talk about fitness grooming style
and
life itself so if you haven't subscribed
yet then please consider it
and also click that notification bell so
you won't miss any of the next
videos now what are the causes
of low sperm count well there's three
main areas that we have to look at we
have to look at
medical environmental and lifestyle now
let's look at
lifestyle first low sperm count can be
caused by drugs
alcohol tobacco or vaping steroids
marijuana and opoids
obesity stress or depression
testosterone boosters
and pre-workout supplements which
contain anabolic steroids
and then certain jobs that require you
to sit down
for long periods of time for example if
you have to sit in front of your desk
the whole day and work on a computer or
if you're a truck driver
okay let's move to environmental factors
next
exposure to pesticides solvents heavy
metals or
industrial chemicals and radiation from
x-rays or
other sources now not a lot of guys know
this
but the ideal conditions for your sperm
to be healthy is actually just a little
bit less than your body temperature
so don't get them too hot like taking
hot showers or
baths or even resting your laptop on
your lap
and you guys that love those hot saunas
at the gym if you spend a lot of time
there not a good idea
if you want to have kids now let's move
on to the next one
medical infection antibodies that attack
sperm
ejaculation problems prior surgeries
celiac disease this is a digestive
disorder
chromosome defects defects of tubules
that transport sperm hormone imbalances
undescended testicles tumors and
certain medications so how do you
increase your sperm count
well first of all you try to avoid all
those environmental
and lifestyle factors and then for the
medical conditions
you can seek treatment for that and then
there are other things that you can do
to increase your sperm count let's start
with the first one
exercise exercise does not just improve
your overall
health but it also increases your
testosterone
and in so doing your fertility
[Music]
zinc this is an essential mineral for
men
that will increase their testosterone
and fertility
you get it in shellfish eggs fish and
meat
and then of course you can also buy zinc
supplements i'll add some good ones for
you in the video description
that you can check out
the aspartic acid supplements this is a
type of amino acid
and it's sold as a dietary supplement
according to a health line parenthete a
study in infertile men suggested that
taking 2.7 grams
of daa for three months increased their
testosterone levels
by 30 to 60 and their sperm count
and motility by 60 to 100
and like always i'll add everything that
i talk about in this video in the video
description down below so it's easier
for you to go and check it out
vitamin d now vitamin d is not just good
for men but also
for women and it's directly linked to
testosterone
and your sperm motility
you can get it from the sun or
supplements
minimize your stress now your stress
doesn't just influence
your mood you know if you're in the mood
too
or not but it also influences your
fertility so just get out of the house
take a break
enjoy nature or go talk to someone do
something
about your stress
vitamin c and antioxidants now
by now you already know how good vitamin
c is
for us i mean you hear it everywhere
and it is also good for your sperm count
and another antioxidant that can help
is beta carotene you can get it
in food like carrots sweet potatoes
winter squash
and apricots
[Music]
sleep again on my channel we're talking
about the importance
of sleep it is so important not just for
your overall health but also even for
your semen if you don't get enough sleep
or if you sleep too much
it will influence your fertility
stay away from soy and other estrogen
rich foods i've already talked about it
on
another video so i'm not gonna go into
it here but
i'll add the video for you in the video
description so you can go and check it
out
after this one ashwagandha
i hope that's how you pronounce it but
it's also known as indian
ginseng a 2013 study followed 46 guys
with low sperm count and they took 675
milligrams of it
for three months every day and their
sperm count increased by 167 percent
fenugreek supplements it's been used by
a lot of people over the years
to increase their sperm health and sperm
count
try it out stay away from unhealthy
fat and eat more healthy fat because yes
those
trans fatty acids unhealthy stuff will
lower your sperm count
and you don't want that so eat more
healthy fat like
nuts avos and fish which will
increase the health of your sperm so
actually the whole thing here is just to
live a healthy
lifestyle and if you're not sure how to
do that exactly then please watch this
video here
and i'll see you there cheers guys